see I would warn about the elves out
left sounds made up yeah what what is
that what are they alternative to the
right of it's the ideas that's young
right so okay like but [ __ ]
so like the right if you think of
conservative you would think of like
Lindsey Graham you think of like people
that are probably racist but they keep
it under wraps slippery shoes Lindsey
Graham was a chick until this week dude
I thought it was a six million dollar
woman well he's got that southern accent
that you can't tell if it's gay or or
not because it's the same thing it's
like ah well yeah yeah there's this is
weird watching these Cavanagh hearings
the whole thing is so strange oh you got
a pot you got to keep your head down if
you do not agree with the like I just I
just tweeted that can you imagine
defending your high school yearbook
that's all we did
I saw that and it was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
show I saw that yeah I was like it was
like I'm [ __ ] out yeah you can't
people can't recognize that you're not
in support of this guy you're not in
support of anything like but it's it's a
real thing signal simply so that people
know I'm on your team I'm just I'm just
a [ __ ] comedian I'm just making an
observation really can you imagine your
high school yearbook do you remember you
remember Hicks's bit about Clarence
Thomas no no I'm sure I've heard it
Hicks had a bit about Clarence Thomas
when they were they were trying to bring
him into Supreme Court oh man I wish I
could remember exactly how the bit went
but it's a great bit but it was about
his porn collection
you know like mr. Herrick oh yes with
clam lapis funny bit but like yours
examining that wasn't funny by the way
Lindsey Graham what did you see like
after he left where they decided they
voted on that
well the voters that's gonna move to the
floor but they decided like you know
we'll try to do this extra week of the
FBI investigation and then he goes
someone's gonna have to explain this to
Trump I guess that'll be me not so
subtle way being like dum-dum doesn't
get it so Trump said to one of the
[ __ ] reporters today know what a
female reporter said he goes he pointed
to a woman and he said go ahead and he
goes she can't but she's speechless she
can't believe I called on her any and
she goes well I didn't think yeah you
don't think yeah I get that I'm sorry
and she goes I'm sorry sir like listen
to this listen this listen this you
never do was Jesus this is listen this
he can't help himself he's crazy
that's okay I know you're not thinking
you never do no go ahead whoa whoa
there's a president that's such a crazy
thing to say to someone no I know you're
not thinking you never do she must be
someone that's written really negative
things of course he knows you know he's
got that hit list and everyone is this
that piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah of
course it's all whole things man he
keeps a record here they have records of
you know anyone who slided him anyone
who's written anything bad said anything
for sure man see